Now we'll talk
for the distribution of Maxwell-Boltzmann.
This is a portrait of the scientist
James Clark Maxwell.
this is my favorite portrait,
here is with his wife Catherine Maxwell and their dog.
James Maxwell is one of the titans of physics,
known for Maxwell's equation.
He makes fundamental developments
in color photography
and think about the issue of distribution
of particle velocities
in an ideal gas.
The other gentleman is Ludwig Boltzman.
He is considered one of the founders
of statistical mechanics.
The distribution of Maxwell-Boltzmann bears that name,
not because they both cooperated,
but reach each other independently.
Each of them describes the distribution
of air particle velocities.
Let's get some sleep
for a thought experiment.
We have one court.
Here is this.
There is air in it.
The air consists mainly of nitrogen.
To make it simple, let it be full of nitrogen only.
I'll paint nitrogen molecules.
We have a thermometer.
I put him in court.
The thermometer shows
exactly 300 degrees Kelvin.
What does 300 Kelvin mean?
We have everyday life
sensory temperature sensation.
We do not want to have hot things.
Let's not get caught.
Or too cold things to keep from trembling.
So our brain
perceives the term temperature.
But what happens at the molecular level?
There is one very accurate
way to imagine the temperature:
in the language of physics,
temperature
is proportional to the average kinetic energy
of the molecules in the given system.
I will write it this way:
the temperature is proportional to the average kinetic energy.
The average
kinetic
energy
in the system.
I add the "Average" refinement.
To be more specific,
let's imagine we have two courts.
This is one,
and this is the other one.
These are two other courts.
Let's say they contain
the same number of nitrogen gas molecules.
I will draw 10.
Obviously, the example is not realistic:
in reality there are many more.
But to get an idea
are enough at ten.
Assume that
the temperature here is 300 Kelvin.
The temperature of the first system is 300 Kelvin.
And the temperature of the second system is 200 Kelvin.
Imagine what these molecules do.
They move around, push,
are not in sync.
The average kinetic energy of the molecules
in this system is greater.
Take this molecule.
It can move in that direction.
That's her speed.
The other particle has that velocity.
Tai goes on,
and this may almost not move.
The next can hurry a lot.
And let this move very fast.
This is what,
the other,
and this.
If you compare this system with this,
you will still find a separate molecule,
which moves very fast.
It can even move faster
from any molecule in the first system.
But the average kinetic energy
of molecules here is lower.
For example, this does so.
I paint ...
Their average kinetic energy is smaller.
This does not mean that each of these molecules
is slower than any of the molecules in the first system,
or has less kinetic energy than it.
But the average kinetic energy of these is smaller.
We can draw a distribution curve.
We call that
distribution of Maxwell-Boltzmann.
Let's do it.
We draw a coordinate system.
This is mine.
On this axis I will display the speed.
Like this.
And the other axis will be the number of molecules.
Number of molecules here.
For the first system, which is at 300 Kelvin,
distribution may look like this.
Now I will draw an example distribution.
Let me use a different color.
This is how they are distributed
all molecules in the system
by number according to your speed.
Like this,
this is the distribution of Maxwell-Boltzmann
for this system,
to call it system A.
This is the one here.
The other system, which has a lower temperature,
which means that it has lower kinetic energy,
there is another distribution of its particles.
Most likely with her
the largest number of molecules
have a lower speed.
For example,
here.
Its distribution appears to be
in such a way.
I draw it in yellow.
Surely it seems logical,
that the speed at which I will have the most molecules
in system B will be lower,
than the speed with most molecules in system A.
This is because the average kinetic
energy here is lower.
The average speed is smaller.
But why is the tip here higher?
Let's recall the two systems
have the same number of molecules.
Thus
the areas under both curves must be equal.
Once this curve is narrower, it should be higher.
If we increase
the temperature of this system even more,
For example, if I warm it up
to 400 degrees Kelvin,
then the distribution
will be so.
This is for a higher temperature system.
Heated system.
This is the distribution of Maxwell-Boltzmann.
I will not show his complex equation,
but this is its essence.
And it's a pretty logical idea.
When you think about speed
of individual particles, for example by air,
you may seem seemingly motionless.
But imagining that the air around you is mostly nitrogen,
you can understand the most probable speed
of an arbitrary nitrogen molecule
from the air around you.
I will now write
its most likely speed.
You may be surprised.
At room temperature,
possible speed
of the nitrogen molecule
at room temperature.
Let's say this is the distribution
of Maxwell-Boltzmann for nitrogen at room temperature.
In our example,
that the room temperature is 300 Kelvin.
Most likely speed
is the one for which we have the largest number of molecules,
who are moving
at such a speed.
Try first to know what it is before telling you:
may be surprising!
It turns out that at temperature
300 kelvin this speed is approximately
422 meters per second!
A total of 422 meters in one second!
Imagine how something goes 422 meters for just a second.
In the more familiar unit of measurement,
it's over 1500 kilometers per hour!
So right now
around you
the largest number
of the nitrogen molecules
move at speed around this
and they hit you.
This is what creates the air pressure.
And not only at such a speed, there are molecules,
which move faster than that.
Faster and 422 meters per second.
Much faster.
Some of the particles around you are moving
thousands of miles an hour
and they hit you in your body at that moment.
You may wonder why it does not hurt?
This gives you an idea of ​​how small the table is
of the nitrogen molecule,
when he pushes you with thousands of miles an hour
and yet you do not feel it.
It only feels like ambient air pressure.
At first glance, it seems unimaginable:
422 meters per second,
is this faster than the speed of the sound?
The sound moves at approximately 340 meters per second.
How is that possible?
Just think about it.
The sound spreads over the air,
by the collisions of its particles.
Therefore, air particles,
or at least some of them,
should move faster than the sound.
Well, not everything around you
is moving so fast
and in different directions;
some particles may be almost immobile.
But some of them move extremely fast.
Is not that great?